[Music]
bachelor in paradise is back up and
running after shutting down production
to investigate that headline-making
incident with Corinne and de Mario and
tonight we are learning more about what
happened from one of the contestants a
man to stand she's the first to open up
since production resumed it's gonna be a
crazy party
I got asking you pretty tan you just got
back from paradise how was it once
filming
resumed once filming started back up we
were also over all the drama and
everything and we were just so excited
to be back after taking a two-and-a-half
week break the crew only had 11 days to
finish shooting the season it was just a
little more fast-paced we did like Rose
ceremonies every other night and was
intense
Amanda confirms the cast also had to
follow new rules set by production when
it comes to the consumption of alcohol
including a two drinks per hour max and
asking for a producer's permission to
have sex there's like a room that you
can go in if you want to like spend the
night together
is there a producer at the door of the
room or do you go find a producer yeah
they were like if someone goes in the
room without asking we'll come in there
and ask you so it's like what's awkward
if you just go find them beforehand the
mom of two who met her now ex-fiance
Josh Murray on the show last year won't
say if she found love this time around
we caught up with her as she supported
another Paradise alum Sarah herons
nonprofit she left everyone in bachelor
nation is beyond I'm I'm so grateful
amanda is also close with Corrine and is
excited both Korean and Demario will be
part of the upcoming bachelor in
paradise reunion special I think it kind
of shows that they're both comfortable
being there and just kind of sets the
record straight we're excited to have
them back
[Music]